stranger things is back in production
before we talk about that a moment of
silence for barb alright he the official
stranger things Twitter account posted a
photo of a total read from the upside
out and the gang is all here
- of course barb it was confirmed that
Millie Bobby Brown is returning as 11
there she is front and center we can
finally find out what Hopper was doing
with those photos even though he's not
in this photo but lo and behold Steve
Harrington pear hasn't lost its glorious
bounce but Nancy did get a haircut do it
animal e Bobby Brown's hair is grown out
- at least for the table read but we do
know there is a time jump but the upper
brothers confirm to IGN but it was
partly due to the fact that gay tomate
arouses voice has dropped so we're gonna
have a year time jump here notice Li in
this photo we have two unfamiliar faces
on the ends first stop
Sadie sink she is playing a character
called max and the episode titles were
released a few months back revealing
that the first episode is called Mad Max
which makes that very interesting
because I assume she's gonna have a
pretty significant role in that case and
then there's Dacre montgomery who's
joining the cast has her stepbrother
billy apparently i've met this guy
several times he's an awesome guy he's
from Australia and you'll actually get
to see him first up hi Rangers movie as
a red ranger recent so that comes out in
March we don't know when the second
season of stranger things will
officially be on Netflix for streaming
no it'll probably be later in the year I
imagine it might be around Halloween
time again we don't know but in the
meantime we can just watch the first
season over again
get as much parties all the barban as we
can so we can rest in peace girl